JACKJACQUI:GROWING CONCERNS OVER
MANDATES, MANY LOCAL BUSINESSES
ARE WONDERING WHAT ALL THIS
MEANS FOR YOU.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT HOW COVID HAS
AFFECTED THEIR BUSINESSES ARE DC
AND FLORIDA RESTAURANT OWNERS
DAN SIMONS AND GEORGIOS, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
DAN, I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
YOU’RE IN DC WHERE UNLIKE IN
FLORIDA, THERE IS NO LEGISLATION
BANNING VACCINE PASSPORTS.
IN NEW YORK CITY AS YOU KNOW
THEY ARE REQUIRING TO ENTER
RESTAURANTS.
ARE YOU NERVOUS THAT ANY CHANGE
COULD POTENTIALLY IMPACT YOUR
BUSINESS?
WHAT ARE YOU FEELING AS YOU’RE
SEEING ALL OF THIS DIFFERING
GUIDANCE COME IN?
>> MY PREFERENCE FOR THE ECONOMY
AND FOR SAFETY AND FOR THE SAKE
OF OUR BUSINESS AND EMPLOYEES IS
THAT EVERYBODY GET VACCINATED.
OTHER THAN THAT, IT’S VERY
DIFFICULT AS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER TO TRY TO ENFORCE A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT REGULATIONS
AS WE TRY TO SERVE THE PUBLIC.
JACKIE: GEROGIOS, YOU INDICATED
THAT YOU’RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FLORIDA’S GOVERNOR DECISION TO
BAN VACCINE PASSPORTS AND
SUSPENDED FINES AND PENALTIES ON
PEOPLE WHO FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
LOCAL LEVEL MANDATE BUT THERE’S
CONSIDERABLE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
IN FLORIDA AS WE ARE SEEING IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN DEALING WITH
THAT?
>> WE HERE IN MIAMI BEACH REALLY
DEPEND ON TOURISTS AND, I THINK,
IT’S EVERYBODY’S CHOICE WHO IS
COMING DOWN TO MIAMI AND
EVERYBODY’S RESPONSIBILITIES WHO
IS CONCERNED AND NOT CONCERNED
AND DIFFERENT CASES THAT WE CAN
REALLY -- WE CANNOT SAY
VACCINATION, NOT VACCINATION BUT
HELPING TO BE PROTECTED FROM
COVID.
I THINK EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE IN
HIS RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE
OF HIS OWN HEALTH AND -- AND
STAY SAFE THE WAY THAT HE THINKS
IT’S CORRECT.
JACKIE: DAN, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO
SEE IN ORDER TO AVOID ANOTHER
SHUTDOWN THAT COULD JEOPARDIZE
YOUR BUSINESS BECAUSE YOU GUYS G
HAVE DIFFERENT SET OF CONDITIONS
THAN GEOR GIOS FROM FLORIDA
WHERE HE HE PLEDGES THEY’LL NOT
ANOTHER LOCKDOWN?
>> I WANT TO BE ABLE TO SERVE AS
MANY DINERS AS POSSIBLE.
GET VACCINATED, SCIENCE-BASED
SOLUTION THAT PROTECTS OUR
ECONOMY AND NOT PEOPLE.
NOT COMPLICATED.
JACQUI: ARE YOU ASKING EMPLOYEES
TO GET VACCINATED OR VOLUNTEER
WHETHER THEY HAVE OR NOT HAVE
BEEN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO YOUR
BUSINESS TO TRY TO GET TO THAT
PLACE?
>> WE ARE BOTH ASKING OUR
EMPLOYEES AND ENCOURAGING THEM
AND PROVIDING THE VACCINATION
CLINICS RIGHT AT THE RESTAURANTS
TO HELP THEM.
WE ARE ALSO PROVIDING EDUCATION,
GETTING FOLKS FROM DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THAT MIGHT BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THEIR QUESTIONS OR
HELP THEM GET OVER ANY
HESITATION.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE ARE ENCOURAGING
IT BECAUSE IT KEEPS THEM SAFE
AND HELPS KEEP THE BUSINESS
GOING.
JACQUI: GEORGIOS, WHAT ARE YOU
DOING ON YOUR END AND ARE THEY
HAPPY WITH THE GOVERNOR’S
STANCE?
>> WE ARE DOING TESTS, COVID
TESTS BECAUSE IT PROVES EVEN IF
YOU’RE VACCINATED, YOU CAN GET
COVID OR YOU ARE GETTING COVID
AFTER YOU GET VACCINATED.
SO WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL
WITH EVERYBODY’S PRIVACY AND --
AND TO FORCE PEOPLE TO DO
SOMETHING, THEY DON’T EVEN KNOW
WHAT’S THE CORRECT THING.
I DON’T THINK THE MEDICINE HAS
ENOUGH RESEARCH TO GIVE US A
CORRECT INFORMATION ON WHAT’S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
WHAT WE DO HERE IS -- WE ARE
DOING FREQUENTLY COVID TESTS AND
--
>> JACKIE: I HAVE TO CUT YOU
OFF, WE ARE COMING UP AGAINST A
BREAK.
IF YOU NEED MORE INFORMATION ON
VACCINES AND COVID AND DELTA,
YOU CAN HEAD TO FOXNEWS.COM WE
HAVE PLENTY ON OUR PAGE.